[Music]  this chaos in here  the fun of moon night is getting  introduced to a new superhero in a new  world  it's a real legitimate character study i  can't tell the difference  between my waking life  and dreams  moon knight is a spectacular character's  got an incredibly unique visual look  our job was to kind of put a lens on the  things that had the most uh dramatic  juice and ultimately take the mental  health aspect incredibly seriously  i am  stephen  the way we're tackling the story we  learn about stephen and then learn about  mark what's wrong with you mark  why did you call me mark and they're the  same person  [Music]  the tone is like fight club meets  indiana jones it's a bit dark at times  to tie it into something so vast and  supernatural it's amazing  thank you  every aspect of this show  has a duality and we've shifted the  paradigm  for me what's really exciting is that  it's totally unpredictable  [Music]  you